[Aplausos]
[Música]
la otan la organización del tratado del
atlántico norte la alianza militar más
importante del mundo acaba de cumplir 70
años lo ha hecho en medio de una de las
crisis políticas y diplomáticas más
importantes que ha sufrido en toda su
historia
hoy aquí en visual polític tú y yo nos
marchamos a conocer un poquito mejor a
la otan vámonos
[Música]
queridos amigos bienvenidos a rumanía
seguro que ahora os estáis preguntando
pero alberto que día antes haces ahí
vale esto es un croma pero de verdad que
hemos estado allí
[Música]
seréis como en 2019 la otan está de
aniversario nos hemos ido hasta rumanía
para conocer mejor cómo funciona esta
organización a hablar con algunos
responsables y presenciar en directo
varias maniobras de las tropas de la
otan que han tenido en ese país no me
digáis que no es la mejor manera de
celebrar sus 70 cumpleaños
[Música]
en concreto hemos asistido al ejercicio
bianual vigoroso warriors donde se
simula un escenario de activación del
artículo 5 en el que han participado
este año más de 2.500 soldados el mayor
hasta la fecha donde las tropas se
entrenan para prepararse para la gestión
médica de heridos en un escenario de
guerra
el día 4 de abril del año 1949 se firmó
el tratado del atlántico norte que dio
lugar a la otan la alianza militar más
importante de todos los tiempos a lo
largo de estos 70 años la organización
ha cambiado mucho pero sobre todo ha
crecido si en su origen estaba formada
por 12 países hoy la integran ni más ni
menos que 29 estados unidos-canadá
turquía y otros 26 estados europeos
entre ellos varios antiguos miembros del
pacto de varsovia la extinta alianza
militar formada entre la unión soviética
y sus países satélites
entre ellos el país al que nos hemos
desplazado rumanía miembro de la otan
desde el año 2004
[Música]
en total son 29 pero pronto serán 30
tras la inminente incorporación de
macedonia del norte hablamos de una
alianza que representa a casi 1000
millones de personas la mitad del poder
económico del mundo y la mayor parte del
gasto militar
una organización con estructuras de
mando conjuntas y tropas que se entrenan
juntas para poder responder de forma
coordinada ante una crisis
[Música]
un poder sin precedentes en toda la
historia y es que amigos estos 29 países
que forman hoy la otan acumulan juntos
un gasto militar anual de más de un
billón de dólares es decir casi las tres
quintas partes de todo el gasto militar
de todos los países del mundo
sin embargo un momento a pesar de
acumular la mayor parte del gasto
militar del planeta de ser más grande y
poderosa que nunca antes la otan no
atraviesa precisamente por sus mejores
momentos es algo de lo que visual
político ya os hemos hablado en varias
ocasiones pues bien en este y en un
siguiente vídeo vamos a ver con detalle
qué está ocurriendo y cómo ha ido
evolucionando la otan con el paso de los
años a qué amenazas se enfrenta y cuál
puede ser su futuro lo vamos a ver pero
antes antes veamos un poquito de
historia
[Aplausos]
la amenaza del ejército rojo
en la década de los 40 está a punto de
llegar a su final hace apenas 4 años que
la segunda guerra mundial ha terminado
[Música]
el mayor conflicto de todos los tiempos
ha dejado consigo decenas de millones de
personas que fueron víctimas de la
guerra la enfermedad y sobre todo de la
brutalidad política de ideologías
totalitarias el final de la segunda
guerra mundial supuso si la derrota del
nazismo pero al mismo tiempo también el
surgimiento de una nueva brecha que
dividiría en dos durante décadas no sólo
a europa sino también al mundo
[Música]
amigos había comenzado la guerra fría en
aquel momento europa era un continente
devastado económicamente hecho trizas y
con sus ejércitos desmovilizados
[Música]
pero existía una importante diferencia
según aquel lado de europa mirásemos
europa del este- quedó bajo el control
de la unión soviética que mantuvo
durante muchos años a más de 5 millones
de soldados en la región frente a ello
la presencia de tropas en el continente
de eeuu y el reino unido- se estaba
reduciendo muy rápido tan sólo entre
1945 y 1946 los contingentes desplegados
en la europa continental por estos dos
países pasaron de 4.5 millones de
soldados a menos de 900 mil a finales de
los años 40 la diferencia en favor de
las tropas soviéticas era de 5 a 1
[Música]
amigos como veis a finales de los años
40 la diferencia de fuerzas establecidas
en la europa continental era enorme y lo
que es aún peor en aquel momento el
comunismo era una fuerza política en
expansión en prácticamente todo el mundo
y desde luego moscú tenía muy pero que
muy claro que no iba a reducir su
control sobre europa
[Música]
por ejemplo en 1947 la república
checoslovaca aceptó recibir ayuda del
plan marshall pero al poco tiempo fue
obligada a renunciar por la presión de
moscú apenas un año más tarde en el año
1948 se produce un golpe de estado que
dejaba el país definitivamente bajo
control comunista en ese mismo año de
1948 la unión soviética llevó también a
cabo el bloqueo de berlín occidental que
durante meses tuvo que ser abastecida
mediante un gigantesco puente aéreo con
más de 900 vuelos al día en fin amigos
estas eran las circunstancias que
explican que en aquel momento en europa
accidental hubiera un miedo auténtico
real a que las tropas soviéticas
avanzaron hasta ocupar nuevos países
como por ejemplo la república federal
alemana o incluso toda la región
precisamente por este motivo en 1948
francia reino unido bélgica países bajos
y luxemburgo acordaron en el tratado de
bruselas una clave
de defensa mutua pero evidentemente eso
no era en absoluto suficiente así que
rápidamente miraron hacia los eeuu había
que asegurar la defensa de los países
libres de europa
y de esta forma es como finalmente el
día 4 de abril del año 1949 12 países
francia reino unido italia países bajos
bélgica luxemburgo islandia noruega
dinamarca portugal canadá y los estados
unidos firmaron el tratado de washington
o tratado del atlántico norte que dio
origen a la otan el primer secretario
general de la otan
florit mail resumió el objetivo de la
alianza como tener a eeuu dentro a la
unión soviética fuera y alemania- debajo
precisamente es en este tratado
fundacional donde se establece el famoso
artículo 5 las partes convienen que un
ataque armado contra una o más de ellas
que tengan lugar en europa o américa del
norte será considerado como un ataque
dirigido contra todas las partes es
decir este acuerdo fue claro todos para
uno y uno para todos esperamos crear un
escudo contra agresiones y el miedo a
ser agredido un baluarte que nos
permitirá continuar con el verdadero
propósito del gobierno y la sociedad la
misión de lograr una vida más plena y
feliz para todo
nuestros ciudadanos harry truman
presidente de los eeuu
[Música]
pero bien continuemos en el año 52 se
sumaron a la alianza
turquía y grecia y tres años más tarde
en 1955 la república federal alemana y
fue entonces ese mismo año cuando la
unión soviética y los países de su
órbita
excepto yugoslavia crearon su propia
alianza el pacto de varsovia una alianza
que aglutinaba todo el poder de los
países socialistas de europa
hablamos de más de 6 millones de
soldados 65 mil tanques 15.000 aviones
de combate 2000 buques de guerra y
misiles nucleares repartidos por los
estados miembros
europa quedaba así dividida y enfrentada
por dos grandes alianzas militares ahora
bien llegados a este punto puede que os
estáis preguntando qué ha supuesto
realmente la otan cuantas misiones
cuántas intervenciones ha liderado cómo
ha cambiado atentos
[Música]
aquí
el año decisivo
[Música]
tras la caída del muro de berlín y el
derrumbe de la unión soviética la otan
una organización que había nacido para
hacer frente a la amenaza soviética no
redujo su actividad todo lo contrario
poco a poco comenzó a tener un papel
mucho más activo en europa y fuera de
europa en todo este proceso 1999 fue un
año clave
[Música]
este año tres nuevos países se sumaron a
la alianza polonia hungría y la
república checa ni más ni menos que tres
países que habían pertenecido al pacto
de varsovia y que por tanto habían sido
países enemigos durante décadas
wright uno de camps hombre diplomático
[Música]
wow
motion y se relative count
sanz
eldad which is software natural science
es el sol sus registros
[Música]
organization
en el registro
con el extremo rifas asiste cúmplase
lirios organizase dan white ravens de
pastor
fase del backup y de guantes virtual de
wii fit
a las seis de la tarde
fue el comienzo de un proceso que con el
paso de los años ha llevado a la otan a
casi la mayoría de los países de europa
del este que formaban parte del área de
control soviética letonia lituania
estonia bulgaria rumanía incluso albania
una enorme ampliación de la otan que ha
enfurecido mucho a la élite política
rusa pero que le ha dado a la
organización más fuerza además de
contribuir decisivamente a que los
países de la antigua órbita soviética
que ahora pertenecen a la alianza
pudieran acelerar y consolidar sus
reformas sin miedo a sufrir represalias
pero hoy amigos no termina todo 1999 fue
también el año donde la otan llevó a
cabo su primera gran ofensiva intervino
en la antigua yugoslavia para frenar la
limpieza étnica que el líder serbio
slobodan milósevic estaba llevando a
cabo contra la población albanokosovar
para frenar al gobierno serbio la otan
llevó a cabo duros ataques contra
objetivos políticos y militares
[Música]
ah
amigos el espíritu de la otan había
cambiado ya no se trataba sólo una
organización defensiva
e
[Música]
en un momento dado se llegó incluso a
especular con una posible invasión
terrestre de serbia por parte de tropas
de la otan y sabéis que según se cuenta
el entonces líder ruso boris yeltsin
humillado enfurecido porque la otan se
hubiera atrevido a incluir en su alianza
a países de europa del este
amenazó ni más ni menos que con la
tercera guerra mundial si las tropas de
la otan intentaban ocupar serbia rusia
respondería he advertido a la otan a los
norteamericanos y a los alemanes de que
no nos empujen a una acción militar en
otro caso habrá con seguridad una guerra
europea y puede que mundial boris
yeltsin presidente de rusia
[Música]
en cierto modo años más tarde en 2008
las amenazas de moscú se convirtieron en
una realidad el acercamiento de la
georgia de mijaíl saakashvili a la unión
europea y sobre todo a la otan condujo
al gobierno ruso a desencadenar una
guerra contra este país es algo de lo
que por cierto os hemos hablado en uno
de nuestros primeros vídeos aquí en
visual político el caso amigos es que
durante los últimos años hemos visto una
organización mucho más activa además de
las continuas ampliaciones y de la
intervención en serbia la otan ha
intervenido también en afganistán en
irak y en libia
y esto es algo que ha generado una
enorme controversia este es el debate
hoy tiene la otan que convertirse en una
institución que actúe allí donde sea
necesario para proteger a sus miembros
incluso si no son directamente atacados
debe actuar en caso de que los derechos
humanos se estén violando de forma grave
en algún lugar del mundo o por contra
debe limitarse a ser una alianza
exclusivamente de defensa es decir
limitarse a actuar solo en caso de que
un país miembro sea atacado militarmente
[Música]
resumiendo tiene hoy la otan futuro tal
y como está concebida
[Aplausos]
y ojo porque las implicaciones de este
debate son enormes al fin y al cabo
estamos hablando del futuro y del papel
de la alianza militar más importante de
todos los tiempos
hablamos de un debate que está en
primera línea y que en los últimos
tiempos ha tenido como protagonista
indiscutible al mismísimo presidente de
los eeuu donald trump que cree que la
otan ya no sirve no tiene sentido está
obsoleta
el dinero de los delincuentes
y aquí es donde nos surge otra cuestión
hasta ahora la otan ha funcionado
siempre bajo el liderazgo de estados
unidos pero podría funcionar y tener
futuro si los eeuu abandonarán no la
alianza pero si esa posición de
liderazgo es compatible la otan con una
nueva estructura militar europea
de todo esto en cierto modo ya os hemos
hablado aquí en visual político en
alguna que otra ocasión pero amigos en
un próximo vídeo lo vamos a ver con todo
lujo de detalles
[Música]
de momento amigos lo que sí podemos
decir más allá de los problemas y de los
errores que se hayan podido cometer es
que la otan ha tenido un enorme éxito me
explico hoy en europa se vive en un
entorno de paz seguridad y cooperación
entre países
vamos que somos algo así como una
pandilla de buenos amigos y ojo porque
podemos cometer el error de pensar que
esto siempre fue así nada más lejos de
la realidad durante siglos en europa los
conflictos y las guerras entre países
formaron parte de la rutina y desde
luego tras la segunda guerra mundial
se mascaba la tensión entre el bando
occidental y el bando soviético y ahí la
otan cumplió con su propósito a la
perfección incluso aunque sus países
miembros no siempre se hayan llevado
bien y hayan tenido sus más y sus menos
como cuando francia se retiró de la
estructura militar conjunta lleno de la
alianza en 1966
en fin amigos esta es la historia de
cómo nació creció y cambió la otan en un
próximo vídeo vamos a ver qué significa
hoy y aquí amenaza se enfrenta así que
ya sabes para no perderte lo suscríbete
a visual político un saludo y hasta la
próxima
[Música]